die bundesweiten ausgangs beschränkung
wirken das ist aus den aktuellen zahlen
ziemlich gut heraus zu lesen und der
kollaps des gesundheitswesen rückt damit
deutlich nach hinten ist vielleicht die
trendwende geschafft kriegst du sonst
wirklich nix täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocke und dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
das sind wirklich sehr gute nachrichten
wir sind noch mal tiefer in die daten
eingestiegen und haben uns jetzt damit
beschäftigt wie sich die täglichen neuen
fallzahlen gegenüber denen des vortags
verhalten und das zeigt verblüffende
ergebnisse eins muss man allerdings
sagen in diesen zahlen steckt keine
gewissheit und es kann sich täglich
ändern
doch der trend über mehrere tage geht in
eine gute in eine sehr gute richtung
auch wenn über die wochenenden scheinbar
weniger fälle gemeldet werden in einem
sind sich die fachleute einig wenn sich
die täglichen neuen fälle nicht mehr von
tag zu tag erhöhen
dann sind wir tatsächlich über den berg
dann ist das maximum erreicht und etwa
eine woche später dürfte auch die zahl
der schweren fälle in den krankenhäusern
sich stabilisieren und nicht mehr zu
nehmen so wäre das ideale szenario und
wir scheinen es tatsächlich zu erreichen
wenn wir die entwicklung der zahlen
ansehen vor allem am wochenende ist die
anzahl der neuen fälle sogar von tag zu
tag gesunken das ist wirklich der hammer
allerdings könnte es auch einfach daran
liegen hat es ja gerade erwähnt dass am
samstag und sonntag einfach weniger
gemeldet wird doch dann müssten die
zahlen am montag deutlich steigen und
diese entwicklung wieder ausgleichen
doch das ist letzte woche nicht passiert
und das ist auch diese woche nicht
passiert nachdem die neuen fallzahlen
von donnerstag auf freitag um 10,9 und
von freitag auf samstag sogar um 35,5
prozent gesunken waren stiegen sie dann
nach nur wenig an von samstag auf
sonntag um 4,9 aber wichtiger von
sonntag auf montag lediglich um 7,4
prozent und das zeigt einen deutlichen
trend über die letzten wochen und den
sehen wir an den steigerungsraten der
täglichen neuen fallzahlen und die
gegengerade auch im langfristigen trend
durch die null linie nach unten
das heißt sie sinken eben langfristig
jetzt verdoppeln sie sich nur noch alle
elf tage das sind extrem gute nachricht
wir beziehen uns dabei auf die zahlen
der johns hopkins university um die
datenkonsistenz
zu halten in dieser situation kann
trotzdem noch nichts an den bisherigen
maßnahmen geändert werden erst wenn
dieser wert deutlich nach unten unter
die null geht dann kann reagiert werden
mit den neuen zahlen rückt die
überlastung unseres gesundheitssystems
deutlich nach hinten in die zukunft oder
und das scheint jetzt wahrscheinlicher
kann sogar ganz vermieden werden im
moment ist die lage jedenfalls absolut
konsistent mit den prognostizierten
zahlen für gestern hatten wir 1269 fälle
in den krankenhäusern erwartet es war
1218 am sonntag waren es 1100 24
prognostiziert haben 4106 sprich man
kann das ganz gut abschätzen und das
funktioniert und das bedeutet bei aller
vorsicht aus den unterschiedlichsten
gründen andere altersgruppen werden
infiziert oder krankenhäuser sind schon
überlastet wie in würzburg kann sich das
immer auch deutlich ändern aber
unabhängig davon sieht es nach den
bisherigen erkenntnissen danach aus dass
eben rund fünf prozent der infizierten
auf der intensivstation behandelt werden
müssen bzw auch beatmet werden müssen
und die zahlen der fälle in den
krankenhäusern den aktuellen fallzahlen
etwa acht tage hinterher laufen
mit diesen informationen und der jetzt
gebremsten entwicklung liegt ein
möglicher kollaps deutlich weiter in der
zukunft wir haben immer mehr gemeldete
behandlungsplätze aktuell sind es 9000
169 die als frei beziehungsweise 24
stunden frei gemeldet sind und es sieht
danach aus dass weitere 10.000 plätze
noch geschaffen werden können aber wie
schon in einem früheren video gesagt
habe der engpass denen es noch zu
beheben gilt das ist das personal das
die geräte bedienen kann allerdings
haben wir bei der jetzigen entwicklung
rund zwei wochen zeit gewonnen und damit
auch zeit gewonnen menschen zu schulen
und neue plätze einzurichten
es ist aber ein wettlauf gegen die zeit
und damit wir den gewinnen ist die
einzige wirklich wirkungsvolle methode
kontakt zu vermeiden zu hause zu bleiben
niemanden zu treffen kontakt sperren
können die katastrophe wie sich jetzt
ganz deutlich zeigt als einzige maßnahme
als abfindung einzige maßnahme
verhindern ansonsten ist sie
unausweichlich also übrigens gibt's
klicks um science-fiction ab sofort als
podcast in der video beschreibung sind
die links zu itunes und spotify also
hier unten und ich freue mich dort auch
auf jeden also bleiben sie gesund
bis dann bleibt dran